foreign
looking for a simple solution to
transfer data quickly and securely
between object and file storage across
Google cloud with storage transfer
service you can securely move data and
create custom configurations for your
data transfer business needs without
writing a single line of code hi I'm
Chloe and in this video I'll be walking
you through storage transfer service and
break down some of the useful features
that can help you with your data
transfer and migration needs
foreign
storage transfer service is Google's
flexible and secure way to transfer data
between object and file storage across
Google Cloud Amazon Azure on-premises
and more all through a single easy to
use interface
it allows you to complete large-scale
data transfers quickly and efficiently
with storage transfer service you can
transfer petabytes of data from on-prem
sources or other clouds over online
networks billions of files at tens of
gigabytes per second
plus the ability to configure your data
transfer to meet your business needs
manage cost time and schedule
with storage transfer service you can
reduce your infrastructure costs by
moving your data storage and application
infrastructure to Google cloud while
minimizing downtime all of this plus
security and reliability built in every
step of the way including data
encryption and validation to encrypt
data in transit support VPC service
controls and use checksums to perform
data Integrity checks ensuring your data
arrives intact
incremental transfer to always move
files and objects that are new updated
or deleted since the last transfer
minimizing the amount of data that needs
to be transferred as well as metadata
preservation to give you complete
control over preserving data object and
file metadata during transfer
storage transfer service is used in a
variety of use cases
this includes analytics and machine
learning so your data is enabled for
projects via data pipelines that are
hybrid or run across multiple clouds or
Cloud regions allowing you to take
advantage of Google Cloud's analytics
and machine Learning Suite
data center migrations to move from
existing infrastructure to the cloud
content storage and delivery to push
your media assets from other clouds or
your private data center into
multi-regional setups designed for video
streaming and frequently accessed
content like websites and images as well
as disaster recovery backup and archival
for scheduling incremental syncs to
enable disaster recovery for apps
running in other clouds and on-prem to
meet your recovery goals
think storage transfer service may be a
good fit for your data transfer needs
learn more and see our full list of
migration Solutions and services offered
by Google Cloud at the link listed on
the screen or check out the description
notes on this video for more resources
to get started with storage transfer
service today
[Music]